I'd like you to draw it the same way so
you can see I've got it leaned over it's
the same diagram it's just gonna make
what we're about to do a teeny bit
easier okay once you've got that diagram
on your book in your page I want you to
look at it and tell me what is strange
about this question in the context of
trigonometry is this the kind of
question we're used to encountering in
trigonometry what's missing a right
angle there's no right angle in sight
and there's an angle up here which you
think oh maybe that's a right angle but
it's not have a look
you've got seventy three and thirty five
that's a hundred and eight that makes
that seventy-two this is no good okay
now yeah was it yeah I'll get to the
title in a minute you can see I've left
it off intentionally okay now there's no
right angle in this triangle so
therefore I'm going to find it really
hard to use trig because all of the
things I know about trig so far have
been to do with right angle triangles
well yeah that's right now here's the
thing I don't draw this because you've
already got this we found takes it oh we
found trigonometry in the unit circle by
doing what what did we do we drew one
there so we're like there's no writing
triangle no problems just put one in
right and then once you work everything
out then you're like oh don't worry now
that I know what this point is I can
forget that the triangle was there I can
hide it as it were now see this triangle
it's not right angled but I'm going to
put a right angle triangle in it in fact
I'm gonna do two can you divide this
triangle down like this
okay now this is why I asked you to sort
of rotate it around just to make this
bit a little bit easier now you might
think that that's a bit of a step
backwards because I don't know what this
lengthy is anyway so how is it useful to
me well just watch and see okay I don't
know what this length is stay with me
Newton I don't know what this length is
but thankfully I have a whole field of
mathematics that deals with numbers that
I don't know what they are
algebra I'm just going to call this guy
H why do you think I call it h it's
that's how tall it is okay so I'm just
gonna call it H for height and once I
have that number there that pronumeral I
should say this is the brilliant part
I'll never find out what it is but I
don't need to I just use it there to
help me out for the number I really want
okay so watch this okay have a look at
this left-hand triangle over here this
little triangle with a 2.3 and H and 73
okay I can say in this triangle that
sine of 73 degrees is what have a look
because it's a right angle triangle
right it's opposite on hypotenuse do you
agree H on 12.3 okay no big deal I can
therefore say that H is this I'm just
multiplying both sides by 12.3 is that
okay now if I wanted to I could go ahead
and I could punch that into my
calculator but watch this I don't need
to okay see this see this it's from this
triangle on the left hand side right but
look there's another triangle on the
right hand side which also has H in it
okay so what I'm trying to do here this
is the skills not about the number it's
about what's happening in your brain
okay I can look at the same object from
another point of view and get more
information about it watch in this
triangle I can say sign of the
five is what look carefully this is the
right angle triangle just this one over
here isn't it
opposite on hypotenuse do you agree do
do you see it
opposite 35 and hypotenuse of this
triangle so now I have this does that
make sense I've just multiplied both
sides by a how's your brain doing okay 2
right-angled triangles now here's the
lovely thing I can put these two guys
together cuz they're both talking about
bless you
they're both talking about H so if
they're both talking about H then both
of these things are equal to each other
right so I'm gonna say this a sign 35
equals 12.3 sign 70 faith they're both H
so they must both be equal does that
make sense
now what was i after in the first place
what's the real question it's what's
this guy right the I don't I don't care
about what H is that's why I never
worked it out okay I just want to know
what a is so what should I do to get it
by itself yeah I should divide by this
guy right all over that can you go ahead
pop that into your calculator calculator
maybe give me um give me one decimal
place will do
do it here I did which which line are
you referring to this one yeah I've got
I've looked at H from two different
points of view but it's the same age so
these two things must be the same
because they're both H who's got another
Fabi 20.6 quickly do a sense check does
it look reasonable
it does look reasonable cuz look if I'm
saying this is twenty point six
it's a longer side opposite what angle a
bigger angle that makes sense look big
side big angle little side little angle
does it make sense yes